on a on a sort of more metaphysical and
spiritual level fundamentally
at the end of the day who are we
if we are not
our brains you know yeah who are we that
yeah well this this perspective if we're
going to take it seriously puts
such enormous uh emphasis
on the quality of our environments right
i mean literally the raw these are the
raw materials with which we're
constructing our thought and none of
that really matters if it's all due to
this lump of stuff in our heads but once
we start thinking of you know you we
were talking earlier about metaphors and
another metaphor that i i came up with
and i really like and so i'm going to
mention here is that our brains are like
magpies those birds that collect shiny
bits of and pieces from their
environment and weave them into their
nests and that's really
what our thinking process is like more
than this workhorse you know or this or
this muscle that's another very common
metaphor in our culture that the brain
is like a muscle uh the the brain i
think is really more like um
the brain does its thinking by
assembling
raw materials from our physical
sensations our physical environment our
relationships with other people and then
weaving them into our thought process so
if that's the case then what's all
around us and in us in our bodies and
how well we pay attention to that and
make use of that um really matters and
so it's it's a very it's a deeply
ecological kind of perspective on a
human nature